[Música]
el sindicato de actores de Hollywood
anunció oficialmente que entran en
huelga tras el fracaso en las
negociaciones con los estudios por
mejores pagos y por el uso de la
Inteligencia artificial 160.000 actores
hacen parte del sindicato que se une a
la huelga de guionistas
la corte de constitucionalidad de
Guatemala el máximo tribunal del país
dejó sin efecto la suspensión del
movimiento semilla del candidato
presidencial Bernardo Arévalo por
supuesta corrupción esto luego que el
tribunal supremo electoral ratificara
también que haré evaluará parte del
balotaje el 20 de agosto
y la Corte Internacional de Justicia
falló a favor de Colombia en el litigio
con Nicaragua que buscaba ampliar su
plataforma continental Más allá de las
200 millas náuticas el tribunal
determinó que tanto la plataforma
continental como la zona económica
exclusiva de Colombia Se preservarán
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos este
Informativo en Estados Unidos por
primera vez en más de 60 años hay un
paro laboral conjunto en Hollywood
160.000 actores de cine y televisión se
sumarán desde el viernes a la huelga en
la que entraron los guionistas en mayo
ellos se quejan de recibir bajos
salarios y de tener contrataciones cada
vez más cortas mientras que las
productoras se defienden diciendo que
las plataformas de streaming las han
obligado a recortar el presupuesto
Manuela caro nos cuenta más
lo que parecía inminente ahora es una
realidad el sindicato de actores de
Hollywood entra en huelga así se une a
los guionistas de cine y televisión en
paro desde mayo la huelga comenzará Esta
media noche todos nosotros miembros del
sindicato dirigentes y personal
estaremos en las líneas de huelga mañana
por la mañana la huelga de 160.000
actores llega tras el fracaso de las
negociaciones con los estudios tanto los
actores como los guionistas exigen
aumentos en los salarios base y en los
salarios residuales al mismo tiempo de
mandar garantías de que su trabajo será
protegido de la Inteligencia artificial
llegamos con gran tristeza a esta
encrucijada
pero no teníamos otra opción
somos las víctimas aquí
prevé la interrupción de más programas y
películas la huelga de unos 11.500
guionistas interrumpe la mayor parte de
la producción de la temporada televisiva
de otoño y paraliza el rodaje de
películas de Gran presupuesto
la alianza de productores de cine y
televisión la asociación comercial que
negocia en nombre de Netflix waltísnico
entre otras declaró estar decepcionada
de que se cancelen las negociaciones
Hollywood no presencia o nahuelga doble
desde hace más de 60 años entonces
actores y guionistas luchaban por los
ingresos residuales de las películas
vendidas a cadenas de televisión ahora
queda por ver cómo se solucionará el
conflicto en la época del streaming y la
Inteligencia artificial en Guatemala el
tribunal supremo electoral ratificó en
un comunicado que la segunda vuelta
presidencial se llevará a cabo el
próximo 20 de agosto con los dos
candidatos que ganaron la primera vuelta
al 25 de junio Sandra Torres y Bernardo
Arévalo la decisión iba en contra del
pedido del Ministerio Público de
suspender al movimiento semilla del
candidato Arévalo por un supuesto caso
de corrupción Además este dictamen de la
fiscalía quedó sin efecto por orden de
la corte de constitucionalidad el máximo
tribunal del país
anteriormente esta Fiscalía de Guatemala
había allanado la sede del tribunal
supremo electoral del país después de
Ordenar el miércoles la suspensión de la
agrupación política semilla por presunta
financiación ilícita y falsificación de
firmas
un caos político que se agrava oficiales
de la fiscalía guatemalteca allanaron la
sede del registro de ciudadanos del
tribunal supremo electoral generando más
tensión por su interferencia en el ya
controversial proceso electoral
semilla el Movimiento Político que reúne
voces anti sistema y que está en la mira
de las autoridades prometió seguir en la
contienda política pese a la suspensión
judicial tenemos Claro que la intención
de todo este aparato y montaje ilegal e
inconstitucional es obstaculizar nuestra
participación en esta segunda vuelta
pero el tribunal supremo electoral Ya
abrió la segunda vuelta estamos en la
contienda electoral nosotros seguimos
adelante y no nos vamos a dejar distraer
por estos actos ilegales su oponente
Sandra Torres anunció Una pausa en su
campaña política mientras se aclara la
tormenta que rodea la elección en
relación a todo lo que está sucediendo
hoy hemos marcado
postura en decir que vamos a hacer una
pausa en la campaña política en hacer
campaña y pedir el voto a pesar de que
ya estamos en la segunda vuelta Yo
quiero hacer una pausa porque quiero
jugar limpia quiero queremos
transparencia en este proceso electoral
y hacer una pausa para dar lugar a que
se aclare esta situación
el gobierno nacional se pronunció y
prometió mantener distancia de cualquier
proceso judicial Y respetar la
independencia de poderes pero la
situación inquieta a varios gobiernos
del mundo y organismos de sociedad civil
que temen que esto sea el primer paso
para suprimir la voluntad popular
[Aplausos]
y en la haya la Corte Internacional de
Justicia desestimó la demanda presentada
por Nicaragua en 2013 que buscaba
ampliar su plataforma continental Más
allá de las 200 millas náuticas que
delimitan la frontera con Colombia con
13 votos a favor y cuatro en contra el
tribunal determinó que tanto a la
plataforma continental como la zona
económica exclusiva de Colombia Se
preservarán cerrando litigio entre ambos
países Nicaragua ya reconoció el fallo
de la corte
será el fin del conflicto la Corte
Internacional de Justicia negó la
petición que hizo Nicaragua en 2013 para
extender su plataforma continental Más
allá de las doscientas millas náuticas y
que interfería con la zona económica de
Colombia
la corte ha concluido que bajo la ley
internacional el derecho de los estados
a una placa continental Más allá de las
200 millas náuticas desde la línea base
no se debe extender Más allá de las 200
millas desde la línea base de otros
estados lo siguiente considerando estos
puntos técnicos y científicos Nicaragua
no tiene derecho a una placa continental
extendida a 200 millas náuticas desde la
línea base de la costa de Colombia
el conflicto limítrofe entre ambos
países se remonta el siglo pasado pero
en 2001 Nicaragua realizó la primera de
tres demandas ante la haya pedí a la
soberanía sobre las islas de San Andrés
Providencia y Santa Catalina en ese
momento la corte otorgó la soberanía de
esas Islas a Colombia pero obligó a
ceder casi 75.000 kilómetros cuadrados
del Mar Caribe al país centroamericano
luego Managua denunció a Bogotá por
realizar actividades de pesca y
patrullaje en las aguas que la corte
recién le había otorgado y ganó el fallo
en el tercer caso sentenciado hoy
Nicaragua reclamaba que se definiera los
límites Más allá de las 200 millas
náuticas sobre la base de la plataforma
continental que se extiende desde su
territorio pero la corte falló a favor
de Colombia y reafirmó los límites que
había definido en 2012 sobre una zona
con ricas reservas de gas y petróleo el
daño que le han hecho a Nicaragua pese a
la derrota en la corte el representante
de Nicaragua firmó que su país salió
bien y que estuviera en el fallo la
corte aclaró que la de la sentencia
depende única y exclusivamente de la
buena voluntad de los estados este
jueves el presidente de la asamblea
nacional de Venezuela el chavista Jorge
Rodríguez afirmó que no se permitirá la
entrada a ninguna misión de verificación
de la Unión Europea a quien acusó de
colonialista de Cara a las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 la advertencia
llega luego de que el parlamento europeo
calificará de arbitraria e
inconstitucional la decisión de
inhabilitar a opositores al gobierno
anteriormente nuestra corresponsal en
Caracas Daniela Zambrano nos informó
sobre lo dicho por Rodríguez y las
reacciones en Venezuela
fue una declaración bastante subida de
tono plagada de improperios hacia los
parlamentarios europeos los calificó de
imbéciles groseros colonialistas
advirtió que no iba a permitir que no se
iba a permitir el ingreso una misión de
observación electoral para las
presidenciales en Venezuela previstas
para 2024 y se dirigió directamente a
Joseph bored el acto representante para
los asuntos exteriores de la Unión
Europea dijo que habían violado el
acuerdo refiriéndose a no injerencia por
parte de órganos y extranjeros esta
declaración de Jorge Rodríguez sea el
hemiciclo de sesiones en la sede de la
asamblea nacional y también rechazaron
que la Unión Europea haya exigido la
Constitución de un consejo nacional
electoral equilibrado reacciones al
interno ha habido por parte de
organizaciones no gubernamentales
defensoras de Derechos Humanos como Pro
vea que han dicho que en Venezuela sigue
consolidándose el camino para otras
elecciones presidenciales sin garantías
recordemos que es una exigencia de la
oposición venezolana que haya misión de
observación internacional en unos
comicios para garantizar que sean unas
elecciones libres e independientes hasta
aquí las noticias sigan en France 24
[Música]